wenn ihr noch den fünfzehnten geburtstag
denkt leute weg vielleicht hinter euch
oder noch vor euch und euch dabei
freiheit wie viel geld das wir ausgeben
wird oder ausgegeben habe dann kommen
vielleicht zahlen den kopf wie 50 euro
100 euro wenn ihr richtig auf die kacke
hautfläche 500 euro wenn ihr denkt dass
wir mit diesem geld zum einen krassen
geburtstag gehabt dann muss ich euch
leider enttäuschen leute denn wie wir
heute sehen werden ist das minimum für
einen fünfzehnten geburtstag 12.000 euro
auszugeben und party der superlative
das hier ist keine pompöse hochzeit
sondern eine kinder geboten und so
müssen nämlich kindergeburtstage auch
aussehen ich kann es an der stelle nur
sagen ich meine meine eigene kindheit
war auch so ich habe auch leider ich bin
auch leider definition von diesen
maßstäben hier in extremer armut
aufgewachsen mein zweiter geburtstag hat
auch keine zwölf pause auge kostet er
hat wahrscheinlich 200 euro gekostet
oder so gut dar abend denn so sieht es
aus wenn notiert in mexiko 15 werden wir
begleiten zwei unterschiedliche teenager
an ihrem kind sanierung der führung doch
die hochzeit aussieht in mexiko okay
leute okay ich hab euch gerade einmal
das durchschnitteinkommen in mexiko
ausgerechnet ja das
durchschnittseinkommen liegt bei 19 1340
us dollar umgerechnet natürlich um ihre
eigene währung aber umgerechneten dollar
910 1340 euro bevor du bist nur
durchschnitt personen in mexiko verdient
19.300 40 dollar 7000 euro steuern fast
12.000 euro für das ganze jahr zum leben
und dann kommt eine 50 jährige tochter
dann ist so zeigt papa ich werde dieses
jahr 15 gibt die kohle habito einem
viertel am rand von mexico city ist
nicht nur armut ein problem sondern auch
die hohe kriminalitätsrate und die
geburtstage die 12.000 euro kosten diese
diesen auch problem wenn man ganz
ehrlich sagen sie auch diese polizisten
jetzt hat sich unterwegs sind nicht etwa
darum den drogenhandel einzudämmen oder
die kriminalität oder die
gewaltverbrechen sie sind hier um 15
jährige kinder zu stoppen die von ihren
eltern mehrere tausend euro für den
geburtstag nehmen wollen das ganze heißt
kind sanierung sind so glaube ich also
kind zu kind 15 auf spanisch und an
lloris ist ja also hat der 15 geburtstag
oder der 15
15 jähriger ich muss ganz ehrlich sagen
wahrscheinlich ist es bei euch auch so
ich hatte keinen plan dass das in mexiko
so ein ding ist dass man sich zum 15
geburtstag von seinem kind einfach
komplett die axt ins bein out in
finanzieller hinsicht und einfach
pleitegeht gefühlt heute ist der
wichtigste tag in jennifers leben schon
seit sieben uhr morgens mit zita
frisiert wir deutschen so und auch
eigentlich alle anderen auf der welt ja
okay also der wichtigste tag in meinem
leben wird meine hochzeit oder er dient
der tag der geburt meines ersten kindes
oder überhaupt meiner kinder wird so
mexikaner in der rolle des olg aber was
ist eigentlich für dich der wichtigste
tag in deinem leben
der nämlich 15 werde ich habe das gefühl
dass heute etwas schiefgehen wird seit
gestern bin ich super nervös ich konnte
nicht schlafen und bin schon früh
aufgewacht
es ist wirklich sogar das geht komplett
an unserer welt vorbei müsst ihr über
vorstellbar vor ihr seid 14 und die welt
am nächsten tag fünft sind ich denke
jetzt mal in der zeit zurück als ich 14
war leute da
das mag das war so krass alter da lag
ich aufgeregt im bett war nach der gail
geborgen kommt meine mutter meine
geschwister kommen alle im bett und
gratulieren mir soeben 30 krieg
geschenke und sich so also ich spüre den
druck spüre den leistungsdruck an der
stelle nicht 15 der wichtigste tag in
meinem leben
zu diesen wichtigen
er ist eine große finanzielle belastung
und die familie alles andere als reich
also jetzt aber nochmal also 12.000 euro
diese familie oder sind noch andere
familien dabei also noch ronja ich
glaube überhaupt nicht aber jetzt von
dem was wir bisher gesehen haben sah es
nicht so aus als würden die und eine
million im jahr verdienen oder so selbst
eine million im jahr verdient würde ich
immer aussagen der 12.000 euro für
geburtstags immer noch krank viel geld
aber dann könnte man zu vertreten aber
mir scheint es sind relativ normale
leute so für meine familie ist es
schwierig da wenn ich die finanziellen
mittel haben aber meine eltern haben es
trotzdem hinbekommen dass ich heute
meine eigene party bekomme dass das ist
aber auch ihre nach von den eltern muss
man wirklich sagen also fettes shoutout
jetzt mal auf report kann alle eltern in
deutschland der ganzen welt die obwohl
sie nicht so viel geld haben tag und
nacht brannten um ihre kindern das beste
leben was wir haben können zu
ermöglichen das ist wirklich eine der
wichtigsten sachen die man seinem leben
machen kann nur 20 kilometer entfernt
aber dennoch in einer ganz anderen welt
lädt anerkennen
die 15 jährige in einem noblen viertel
zusammen mit ihrer mutter und ihrem
bruder
okay okay jetzt wo ist dir siehst du wie
switch okay jetzt jetzt jetzt jetzt
denke ich das ganze weil er mich hat
eben schon sagen also 12.000 auch wie
sie beim durchschnittseinkommen ist
einfach ein jahresgehalt von einer
person so das kann ja nicht sein
natürlich haben wir auch noch die
natürlich nicht ich bin heute die
wichtigste person und deshalb ist es für
mich natürlich wichtig super auszusehen
ja also wieder der wichtigste tag im
leben ich frage mich gibt's auf der welt
oder irgendwo im universum auch eine
kultur die so den neunten geburtstag als
wichtigsten tag im eigenen leben einfach
so festgelegt hat gleich gibt's den
planeten so 30 tausend lichtjahren
entfernung so menschenähnliche wesen und
so für der neunten geburtstag vom
nachwuchs verschulden sich so die eltern
dann komplett pleite
feuerrot bin ich gesagt heute bin ich in
die falsche familie eingebunden mal hand
aufs herz
wo war meine eventplaner renten als ich
15 wurde oder 18
da war keine event planerin da ich
musste die ganze karte selbst
organisieren und bin daran extrem
gescheitert ganz ganz ehrlich leute ich
glaube nach diesem video müssen wir alle
mann wird von unseren eltern reden und
fragen wo denn die geburtstags planer
waren damals mit thies ihre cousinen
verwandelt sich die 15-jährige vor allem
für ihre mutter ein bewegender moment
sie so zu sehen geht mir sehr nahe
okay das ist so wie ich wollte heute
gerade schon den job machen schreibt die
mutter so aber ich kann das
nachvollziehen
ich glaube aber an kinder hat und die
halt so kann also die sind auf die welt
gekommen war da und die werden immer
älter und auch einmal wenn halt so ein
krasser schnitt so im leben drin ist man
als elternteil märkte bruder
wo ist die letzten 15 jahre hin dass von
crazy heute ist endlich der tag gekommen
ich fühle mich jetzt wirklich wie 15
einfach schon viel erwachsener okay das
alles geil da gibt es zwei sagt über
dich reden wir erst einmal diese
einwände oder untenende kevin wächst im
luxus auf liebe taft redaktion vielen
dank für diesen hinweis mir wäre es
sonst nicht aufgefallen und auch sie ist
geil so seine romane ich weiß noch als
ich 14 war
ich war so käme wäre dessen macht sich
auch jennifer für die feier fertig da
ihre mutter noch in den party
vorbereitungen steckt helfen alicante
und ihre oma dann sieht es gerade das
ist wirklich krass dass ich finde sowas
immer so krasse unterschiede inzwischen
den leben von leuten zu sehen auch
offensichtlicher weise haben jetzt eine
familie hier die extrem reiches in eine
familie die nicht so reich ist
wahrscheinlich relativ normal lebte
mexiko aber ich weiß gar nicht ob man
wirklich sagen kann dass er eine
geburtstag besser als der andere klar
der eine ist wahrscheinlich größer und
teurer aber bei den geburtstag von der
normalen familie ist keine
wendt planerin dabei aber ich finde das
wirklich suite in wirklich krasse daran
ist wie es den kindern so ultra wichtig
ist und nicht mit den familien auch
extrem wichtig ist und alle sich darum
kümmern einen festsaal kann sich die
familie nicht leisten
deshalb wird in einem zelt direkt vor
dem haus gefeiert alle in der familie
helfen mit um die kosten so gering wie
möglich zu halten
dennoch kostet die feier umgerechnet ca
2000 euro
das ist wirklich crazy also es ist eine
sache wenn so eine todes reiche familie
12.000 euro dafür ausgeben aber als
normale familie die vielleicht in den
bereich von diesen
durchschnittseinkommen von 19.000 dollar
liegt 2000 euro auszugeben
es ist eine tradition die wir von
unseren großeltern kennen
jeder vater ich natürlich auch an diesem
tag für seine tochter nur das beste
das ist dass es leute dass das wird
einen auch fast schon müsste man das
sieht oder wir haben jetzt gerade gesagt
dass er jedes ist der vater von dem
normalen mädchen sag ich mal dass er
einfach monate lang ein halbes jahr lang
doppelt so viel gearbeitet hat wie
normal nur mir die partie bezahlen zu
können und ja ich kann das nicht
nachvollziehen dass der fünfzehnten
geburtstag hat so krass weil es in
meiner kultur einfach nicht so ist aber
ich finde es richtig cool wie krass die
ihre kultur zelebriert und ihrer
tradition projekt geht es erst richtig
los
egal was ihr aussieht wie die krönung
einer königin ist der 15 geburtstag als
ganz normalen teenagers fand ich aber
unkorrekt hat vom papst da ist ja nicht
vorbei gekommen ist muss ich ganz
ehrlich sagen hätte machen können also
das ist das ist schon wirklich
geisteskrank diese tradition aber
wirklich das krasseste für mich dabei
ist wie sich so alle aufopfern und an
dieser tradition einfach festhalten dass
ich meine ich könnte wenn ich jetzt wie
zum beispiel über deutschland nachdenken
dann fallen mir gar nicht so krasse
tradition jetzt so aus dem stegreif ein
die genau so und so intensiv so gelebt
werden wenn ihr irgendwelche der bäche
das gibt in deutschland die mir fällt
einfach gar nicht einfach in den
kommentaren aber das fand ich wirklich
schön zu sehen nachdem messe gilt
jennifer nicht mehr als kind so eine
reaktion gefragt
moment für alle zu treten ich fühle mich
plötzlich ganz anders wie wahnsinnig
dankbar
aha das ist richtig holz im alter das
ist richtig das ist richtig schön zu
sehen
also ja leute ich finde am ende kommt
einfach auf den zusammenhalt in der
familie an und es kommt darauf an wie
sehr die leute sachen rein geben egal
wie viel sie geben können ich finde es
geil dass jeder einfach so im rahmen
seiner möglichkeiten so viel gibt wir
geben kann aber schauen wir auch mal zu
diesem ganzen verrückten dinge und in
die kommentare reichen die finde ich
hier in feucht vorgeschlagen könnte man
kann aber nicht von der strauß macht's
gut